Benim sevgili 9. sınıf öğrencim,
coğrafya okuluna, YouTube'un en büyük
coğrafya kanalına hepiniz hoş geldiniz.
Evet, Zeduva öğretmeninizle beraber
yaptığımız okula destek kampımızın bugün
geldik artık son videosuna. Bugün
bölgeleri ve bölge sınırlarını
öğreneceğiz. Ama bakın, bu konu çok
önemli bir konudur. Çünkü üniversite
sınavına gittiğinizde her sene bir soru
karşınıza çıkar bundan. Tabii ki siz
üniversite sınavına giderken sizin
sınavınız biraz daha farklı olacak. Ama
sonuçta bu konu önemli bir konu ve
buradan soru gelecek sana. O gün soru
geldiğinde benim şu sloganımı
hatırlayacaksın. Yunus Hoca'yla bir defa
öğren, bir daha asla unutma. Çünkü biz
bu 9. sınıf boyunca aslında seni
üniversite sınavına hazırladık. Sen de
öyle hazırlandın aslında, farkında
değilsin. Bunu 3-4 yıl sonra tekrar
üniversite sınavına hazırlanmaya
başladığında anlayacaksın. Evet, ben
bunu biliyordum diyeceksin. Ben şunu
biliyordum diyeceksin. Senin için
üniversite sınavına hazırlanmak coğrafya
dersi için sadece bir genel tekrardan
ibaret olacak. O yüzden şimdi dersi
dinlerken dikkatli dinle ki 3 yıl sonra
rahat et. Sınavda da bu yazılı sınavında
da bundan soru çıkacaktır. Merak etme
diyoruz ve o zaman ne diyoruz? Yunus
Hoca'yla bir defa öğren, bir daha asla
unutma. Zeduva'yla eğitim her yerde.
Evet, geldik bölge ve bölge sınırlarını
öğreneceğiz. Bunun PDF'ini böyle
zeduva.com sitesine yükledik gençler.
Oradan indirip kullanabilirsiniz. Şimdi
bakın, biz bazı sınırlandırmaları
yapmamız lazım ki tanımlamalar
yapabilelim. Yani biz bölgeleri
ayırmazsak nasıl insanlara tarif
edebiliriz? Ya da kendimiz bunları nasıl
tam olarak öğrenebiliriz? Çeşitli
kriterlere göre bölgeleri ayırmak
zorundayız. Çünkü bunlar üzerinden
yatırımlardan tutun da tanımlamalara
kadar birçok işimizi bu bölge
sınırlarının tanımlanması ve
belirlenmesi üzerinden yapıyoruz.
Gençler, geçmişte bölgeleri farklı
ayırıyorduk. Artık farklı ayırıyoruz.
Geçmişte nasıldı biliyor musunuz?
Aslında biliyorsunuz. Karadeniz Bölgesi,
Güneydoğu Anadolu Bölgesi, Doğu Anadolu
Bölgesi gibi bölge sınırları ayrımımız
vardı. Sonra o kaldırıldı. Sonra ne oldu
biliyor musunuz? Aslında mantıklı olan
da bu. Mesela bitki örtüsüne göre
Türkiye'yi bölgelere ayırıyoruz.
Toprağına göre bölgelere ayırıyoruz.
Nüfus yoğunluğuna göre, yerleşimlere
göre, petrol üretim alanlarına göre,
doğal gaz üretim alanlarına göre
bölgelere ayırıyoruz. Bu bölge ayrımı
çok daha kullanışlı, çok daha işimize
yarayacak türden. O yüzden bölgeleri
gençler biz artık yeni kriterlere göre
ayırıyoruz ve karşımıza yeni bölge
türleri çıkıyor aslında. O geçmişteki
Karadeniz Bölgesi, Marmara Bölgesi gibi
ayrımları kullanmıyoruz. Bölge dediğimiz
şeyin tanımını öğrenmen gerekiyor. Çünkü
bu sana yazılıda böyle tanım olarak
sorar öğretmenin. Bak, kendi içinde
çeşitli benzerlikler gösteren, çiziyorum
aynı zamanda ben sana bunu şimdi. Bak,
şöyle bir kare çizeyim. Bu kare
üzerinden anlatayım sana. Bunun şu içini
maviye kareli yapalım, şöyle. Bak, kendi
içinde çeşitli benzerlikler gösteren.
Görüyor musunuz şu maviyi? Bak, bu kendi
içinde çeşitli benzerlikler gösteriyor.
Mavi kareler falan, öyle düşünün. Sonra
fakat çevresinden çeşitli özelliklerle
ayrılan coğrafi birimdir. Bu mavi kare
kendi içinde çeşitli benzerlikler
gösteriyor ama çevresinden
benzerlikleriyle ayrılan coğrafi
birimlerdir bölgeler. Yani sizin asıl
bilmeniz gereken şurası. Bölge
türlerinin şu ayrımını yapabilmeniz
lazım sizin. Gençler, biz bölgeyi ikiye
ayırıyoruz, bakın. Şekilsel bölgeler,
işlevsel bölgeler. Bunu da ezberlemene
gerek yok. Bak, işlevsel bölge dediğinde
birisi sana, "Bir işi kolaylaştırmak
için yapılmış bölgeler." diyeceksin
buna. Bak, işlevsel. Ha, bir işi
kolaylaştırmak için yapılmış bölgeler
bunlar. Mesela belediye yönetim
bölgeleri. Bir iş kolaylaştırmak için
değil mi? Bir merkezi var ve bir işi
kolaylaştırmak için yapılan bölgeler. İş
olacak yani. Bak, bir daha. Bölge
türleri. ha, hocam bir iş lazım bize.
İşlevsel bölge diye ayırdık. Bir de
şekil lazım bize. İş, şekil. Hatta şöyle
yapabiliriz. Şekilin başına i koyarız.
Bak, bu kodlamayı da burada çıkarttım
ilk defa. İş şekil, iş şekil. Böylece
iki tane ayrımı da bulmuş oluruz. Birisi
bize o zaman bölge dediği zaman şekil
diyeceksin. Ha, iş şekil. Ha, hocam,
işlevsel bölgeler, şekilsel bölgeler
olarak ayırağız. Tamam? Merak etme,
şimdi tek tek bunları göstereceğim sana.
Şekilsel bölgelere bak şimdi. Tanıdık
gelmesi lazım sana şekilsel bölgeler.
Bak, coğrafyayı biz kaça ayırıyorduk?
İkiye. Hep ayrımlarımız bunun üzerinden
gidiyordu. Fiziki coğrafya, yani doğal
coğrafya, bir de beşeri coğrafya bakın,
beşeri coğrafya. İşte şekilsel bölgeleri
aynı coğrafya gibi ikiye ayıracaksın.
Coğrafyanın ayrımını yapacaksın burada.
Ha, diyeceksin, hocam şekilsel bölge,
ha, o zaman bunu doğal şekiller, beşeri
şekiller diye ayıracaksın. Bak, doğal
işlevler, beşeri işlevler olmuyor,
görüyor musunuz? Bak, beşeri işlevler
olmuyor. Beşeri şekiller oluyor. Bak,
doğal işlevler olmuyor. Doğal şekiller
oluyor. Ha, demek ki bu işlevsel
bölgenin altında değil. Tamam? Ne
yaptım? Şekilsel bölge dedim. Ha, doğal
şekiller, coğrafya gibi ayırdım, beşeri
şekiller. Anlaştık mı? Bak şimdi, kenara
geliyorum. Bir tane boşluk bulayım. Bu
boşlukta sana bunun mantığını bir kere
daha sen de yazarak öğren. Bir tane
kağıt al. Bu ayrımı yapabilmen gerekiyor
çünkü. Şimdi, bana birisi sor sordu.
Bölgeleri tablo olarak ayır dedi bana.
Hemen bölge yazdım. Sonra dedim ki, ha,
bu bölgelerde şekil vardı. Şekil şekil
şekil. Ha, hocam bak bak, şekil. Ha,
bunun başına bir tane i koyuyordum,
işlevsel bölge. O zaman bir tanesi
şekilsel bölge, diğeri de işlevsel bölge
diyeceksin. Bak, adım adım anlatıyorum.
Hiç Hiç etmiyorum. Sen de acele etme.
2x'ten çıkart bu videonun burasını. Hiç
yoktan 1,25'e 1,5'a düşür, tamam? Çünkü
bunu böyle algılaman gerekiyor. Sonra
baktım, şekilsel bölge. Ha hocam, burada
şekil, doğal şekiller, coğrafyanın alt
dallarını düşünüyordum. Doğal şekilsel
bölgeler, bir de ne vardı? Beşeri,
insanla alakalı. Beşeri şekilsel
bölgeler diye ayıracağım. Bu ayrımı
böyle yapabilmen bizim için çok değerli,
tamam? Şimdi geldim buraya. Bak,
bunların örneklerini hocan sana
sorabilir. Nasıl soracak? Mesela, şöyle
yakınlaşayım. Şekilsel bölgelerden
başlayalım. Bak, yer şekillerine göre
bölgeler. Dikkat et, yer şekli. Sonra
yazar hocan, yer şekline göre bölgelere,
bölgelerden hangisine koyacağız diye. E
hocam, yer şekli doğal bir şey değil mi?
O zaman getirip bunu nereye koyacaksın?
Doğal şekilsel bölgelerin altına
koyacaksın. Bak dikkat et, iklim. İki
tane iklim yazmışız buraya. Hidrografik
bölge. Bak, toprak bölgesi. Bunların
hepsi doğal bir şey değil mi? Bitki,
doğal bir şey değil mi? Doğal afetler,
doğal bir şey. Bak, görüyor musun?
Doğal. Ha, o zaman bunları doğal
şekilsel bölgeye koyduk. Buraya bak
şimdi, hammadde ve üretim. İnsanla
alakalı bir şey var burada. Sanayi,
nüfus. E bunların hepsi insan değil mi?
Bak, yerleşme, kültür, siyasi. Bunların
hepsi ne? İnsanla alakalı. O zaman
getirip bunları beşeri şekilselin altına
koyacağım. Anlaştık mı? Şimdi bunlarla
alakalı örnekleri vereyim sana. Bak,
doğal şekilsel bölgeler. Mesela bak,
dünyadaki kasırga bölgeleri. E bu
insanla alakalı değil ki, doğada yaşanan
bir şey. O zaman ben bunu ne yapacağım?
Hocam hemen burada ayrımını yapalım.
Bak, bölge. Bana dedi ki soruda,
dünyadaki kasırga bölgeleri bölgelerden
hangisine girer? Ha, bölgeyi yazdım.
Sonra dedim ki, bir işi kolaylaştırmak
için bölgeler var. İşlevsel bölge,
şöyle, işlevsel bölge. Bir de şekil
vardı, şekilsel bölge. Hocam bu doğayla
alakalı, o zaman bunu ben doğal şekilsel
bölgelerin altına koyacağım. Anlaştık
mı? Mantığı bu. Bakın, Türkiye'deki
bitki örtüsü bölgelerini koymuş. E neyle
alakalı? Bitki. E o zaman doğal bir şey,
doğal şekilsel bölge. Bak, toprak
tiplerine göre bölge, iklimine göre.
Mesela buraya koymuş bak, Ekvatoral
ikliminin dağılış haritasını koymuş.
Bunu o zaman, he, hocam bu şekilsel ama
nasıl? Doğal şekilsel bölge içerisine
koyacağım. Buradaki mantığı anladınız
mı? Tamam. Bak, yer şekilleri bölgesi.
He, yer şekilleri. He, bu bir işi
kolaylaştırmak için yapılmış bir şey
değil bu. Bu şekille alakalı. Peki
beşeri şekil mi, doğal şekil mi? He,
hocam bu doğal bir şekil. O zaman doğal
şekilsel bölgeye girer diyeceğim. Tamam?
Bu ayrımı bu şekilde yapabilmeniz lazım.
Beşeri şekilsel bölgelere bakalım şimdi.
Bak, burada ne vermiş haritada?
Türkiye'nin yoğun ve seyrek nüfuslu
bölgeleri. Ha, nüfusla alakalı. O zaman
ben bunun hemen tablosunu yapayım. Bölge
dedim. Hocam bu işlevsel bölge olur mu?
Hayır. İş değil bu, bir şekil bu.
Coğrafyanın alt dalı gibi. Peki doğal
olur mu bu? He, bu nüfus insanla
alakalı, doğal değil demek ki. O zaman
buna ne diyeceğim? Beşeri şekilsel bölge
diyeceğim. Buradaki ayrımı ve tanımı ve
öğrenmeyi böyle yapacaksın. Bak, nüfus
öyle. Bak, hammadde üretim bölgesi.
Üretim diyor. İnsanla alakalı. Kültür
diyor. İnsanla alakalı. Yerleşme insanla
alakalı. Bunların hepsi neyle alakalı o
zaman? Beşeri şekilsel bölgeyle alakalı.
Tamam? Geliyorum şimdi. Şu tablonun
başına dönelim. Bir de burada bakın,
işlevsel bölgeler var. İşlevsel bölge
dediğimiz ne biliyor musunuz? Bir işi
kolaylaştırmak için yapılmış bölgeler
bunlar. Bunların bir merkezi var ve bu
merkez doğrultusunda yönetiliyorlar.
Nedir hocam bunlar? Gelin, bakın. Bakın
şimdi şurada, işlevsel bölge. Birincisi
yönetim bölgesi. Şimdi siz Türkiye'yi
yönetim bölgelerine ayırmazsanız
yönetebilir misiniz? Tabii ki yönetilir
ama zor olur, değil mi? Kolaylaştırmak
için ne yapmışlar? Mesela bunu bilmenize
gerek yok illa böyle. Şuradaki kısmı
bilmenize gerek yok. Şunu bilmeniz
yeterli. Demek ki yönetim bölgesi olarak
ayırdım ben. Bak, bir işi kolaylaştırmak
için mi? Bak yönetim işi. Bak yönetim
şekli değil. İşte yönetim doğal şekli,
yönetim beşeri şekli değil. Yönetim işi.
Ha bir işi kolaylaştırmak için yapılmış
bölge demek ki bu. Nasıl ayırıyorlar
bunu? Merkezi yönetimler gençler. Mesela
kaymakamlık, valilik devlet tarafından
atanır ilçelere, illere ve kaymakamlık,
valilik devlet tarafından yönetim yapar.
Bak bunu devlet yapar. Merkezden atanır
bunlar. O yüzden buna merkezi yönetim
denir. Bir işi kolaylaştırmak için mi
yapılmış? Ha işlevsel bölge. Bir tane
daha bu da yerel yönetim bölgeleri.
Yerel yönetimden kastımız da gençler
mesela büyükşehir, il, ilçe, belediyeler
değil mi? Belediyeler bu merkezden
atanmaz, devlet tarafından atanmaz. Bunu
kim yapar? İnsanlar kendileri seçer
belediyeleri. Yani aslında yönetimler
iki şekildedir Türkiye'de. Bir tane
mesela sizin ilçenizde tamam mı? Bir
tane belediye vardır, belediye başkanı
vardır. Bunu halk seçer. Bu yerel
yönetimdir. Bir tane de merkezi yönetim.
Devletin atadığı biri vardır, kaymakam.
O da devlet adına yönetim yapar orada.
Anladık mı oradaki mantığı? Bak bunlar
ne? Yönetim yapıyor. Ha yönetim bir işi
kolaylaştırıyorlar aslında. Bakın
büyükşehir, İstanbul Büyükşehir
Belediyesi. Ha bir işi kolaylaştırmak.
İşlevsel bölge. İşlevsel bölgelerden
hangisine giriyor? Yönetim bölgesine
girmiş oluyor. Buradaki mantığı anladık
mı? Bir diğer bölge türü de gençler
yönetim bölgesi birdi. İkincisi kalkınma
işi. Bak görüyor musun? İş iş kelimesi
nasıl uyuyor? Ha kalkınma işi. Kalkınma
işlevsel bir bölge. Ne demek bu? Gençler
ülkemizde çeşitli kalkınma bölgelerine
ayrılmıştır bizim ülkemiz. Bakın
özellikle doğu kesiminde bu kalkınma
bölgeleri var. Kalkınma bak adı üstünde.
Kalkınma. Çünkü doğuda sanayi
yapamıyoruz. Doğuda imkanlar daha
kısıtlı ya. Devlet oradaki insanların
batıya göç etmesini istemiyor. Herkes
kendi bulunduğu bölgede tarımını,
hayvancılığını yapsın, o bölgede dursun.
Kalkınmamız Türkiye'nin her tarafına
yayılsın diye kalkınma projeleri yapar
devlet. Mesela bunlardan belki senin en
bildiğin, bu biraz AYT konusu, en
bildiğin senin Güneydoğu Anadolu GAP'ı
bilirsin bak. GAP'ı duymuşsundur. Mesela
burada da KOP var, Konya Ovası Projesi
gibi. DAP var, Doğu Anadolu Projesi
gibi. DOKAP var mesela şöyle, DOKAP Doğu
Karadeniz Projesi gibi. Ama bunlardan
GAP'ı bilirsin, GAP Güneydoğu Anadolu
Projesi. Bu proje bir Bunların hepsi bir
kalkınma projesi. Kalkınma işi. Bir
merkezi var bunların, bir işi
kolaylaştırmak için bu bölgeleri
ayırmışız GAP diye. Burada bir iş
yapılıyor. Buranın kalkınması için
çeşitli işler yapılıyor gibi düşün bunu.
Demek ki işlevsel bölgeleri ne yaptık
şimdi? Yönetim işi diye ayırdık,
kalkınma işlevsel bölgeleri diye
ayırdık. Gelelim diğerine, hizmet
bölgeleri bakın, hizmet hizmet işi.
Hizmet şekli olmaz yani. Hizmet şekil
doğal şekiller olmuyor bak. Hizmet işi
var. Ha hocam, hizmet işinde de devlet
hizmet götürecek ya, hizmet bölgelerine
ayırması gerekiyor. Hizmetten kastımız
şu, bakın Devlet Su İşleri hizmet
bölgesi. Görüyor musunuz? Orman Genel
Müdürlüğü hizmet bölgesi. Karayolları
Genel Müdürlüğü bak bunların hepsi
hizmet için varlar. Demek ki bir diğeri
de hizmet bölgesi. Bir diğeri, sonuncusu
şöyle, bu da istatistik bölgeleri.
İstatistik işi var. Bu işi
sağlayabilmemiz için TÜİK gençler
istatistik bölgelerine bölmüş ülkeyi
bakın. Bunlar da istatistik bölgeleri,
istatistik işi. Şimdi en başa geliyorum,
en başa. Şöyle bir tekrar bir görelim
şurayı. Şunları sileyim. Şöyle işlevsel
bölgelere bak, bölgelere ayırdık. Ha bir
şekilsel dedik, ha başına i koyduk iş,
işlevsel bölge diye de bir tane daha
ayırım yaptık. Sonra iş bir işi
kolaylaştırmak için bak, hizmet işi
işlevsel bölge, kalkınma işi işlevsel
bölge, yönetim işi ve istatistik işi.
Bunlar da bizim işlevsel bölgelerimiz.
Bunları aynı böyle bilmen gerekiyor.
Bunlara örnek verebilmelisin. Mesela
sana örnekten kastımız şu, sana derse
kalkınma projesi bölgesi hangi bölge
türüne girer, sen bunun bir iş bölgesi
olduğunu bilmen gerekiyor. Ya da sana
gelip, Türkiye'nin toprak bölgesi
hangisine girer dediğinde, "A, bu doğal
şekilsel içerisine girer." bu ayrımı
yapabilmen gerekiyor. Tamam? Bölge
türlerinin mantığı budur gençler. Mesela
buradan ne, evet, örnekleri verdik
aslında. Bir daha vermeye gerek yok.
Şimdi bir de bölge sınırlarının, bölge
sınırlarıyla alakalı bazı özellikler
var. Bu özellikleri bilmen lazım. Şu
özellik bizim için çok önemli. Bölge
sınırlarının ayrılması. Bak, bunu
dikkatlice dinle. Gençler, bölgelerin
sınırlarını böyle keskin hatlarla
ayırmak zor oluyor. Özellikle de doğal
bölgelerin sınırlarını ayırmak zor
oluyor. Mesela ne demek istediğimi
şuradaki örnekler üzerinden anlatayım.
Şurada. Doğal bölgelerden bir örnek
çıkartayım. Mesela şu. Türkiye'deki yer
şekillerine göre bölgeler. Bunu değil de
daha böyle anlayabileceğiniz, ha, şu.
Mesela Türkiye'deki bitki örtüsüne
bölgeler, göre bölgeler. Şimdi sen
bitkinin sınırlarını kolay ayırabilir
misin? Böyle mi gerçekten? Bu haritada
olduğu gibi mi? Ben bu haritanın
şurasındayken şurasına bir adım
attığımda, şuradayım ya şimdi ben.
Buradan şuraya bir adım attım, ha, bitki
direkt değişti. Ya da iklim, burada
Akdeniz iklimi var, bir adım attım diğer
tarafa, Akdeniz iklimi direkt değişti.
Böyle bir şey olabilir mi? Yok. Demek
kademeli bir geçiş gösterir. Bölge
sınırlarının keskin hatlarla doğal
bölgelerde ayırmak zor oluyor. Doğal
bölgelerden kastımız şuydu bakın. Yani
şuradaki doğal bölgelerde bölgelerin
sınırlarını ayırmak zor oluyor. Bunu
ezberleme. Bunun mantığını şöyle düşün.
Şimdi sen iklim bölgesini sınırını böyle
çizgi halinde çizebilir misin? Çizdim,
burası Akdeniz, burası Karadeniz. Yok
değil mi? Akdeniz'le Karadeniz bazı
yerlerde birbirine geçmiştir, tam olarak
sınırlarını böyle ayıramazsın. İşte en
önemli özelliklerimizden bir tanesi bu.
Bölge sınırlarının ayrılması. Yani doğal
bölge sınırları ayrılırken kademeli
geçiş gösterir, keskin hatlarla ayırmak
zordur. Tamam? Ama bakın, burada beşeri
bölge sınırlarını, işlevsel bölge
sınırlarını daha kolay ayırabiliyoruz.
Mesela beşeri bölgeden kastımız şurası
bak. Tak, ülkenin ne ile, ili ile
alakalı, değil mi? E, ilini içine
aldığımızda tak sınırı belli oldu.
Gördünüz mü? Bak, tak, Ankara'da nüfus
yoğundur dedik. Baktık, sınırını belli
ettik. Ankara'nın il sınırıyla örtüştüğü
için keskin bir şekilde ayırabildik. Ya
da kalkınma bölgesi, bak burada.
Kalkınma bölgesi. Ben gitsem burada
Diyarbakır'ın tam şu uç kesimine ve bu
uç kesiminden bu tarafa gelsem,
Diyarbakır'a gelsem kalkınma bölgesinin
içinde olurum. Bir diğer tarafa gitsem,
mesela orada Bingöl tarafına gitsem bir
adım, kalkınma bölgesinden çıkarım,
değil mi? Bak, ne oldu? Daha böyle
işlevsel bölgeleri keskin hatlarla
ayırabildik, ama doğal bölgeleri keskin
hatlarla ayırmak daha zor oldu. Buradaki
mantık bu olacak. Bununla alakalı sana
böyle bir yorum sorusu sorulabilir. Bir
diğeri, bölgelerin sınırlarının
değişmesi. Bölgelerin sınırı değişir,
değişebilir gençler. Yine aynı mantık
var bakın. Sen şimdi doğal bölgeleri
değiştirmek, doğal bölgeleri
değiştirmeye kalktığında sen
zorlanırsın. Daha uzun zamanlarda
değişir. Mesela yine iklime örnek ver.
Hep bu iklim aklında olsun. Sen şimdi
iklim bir doğal bölge. İklimin değişmesi
çok uzun sürer, değil mi? Yıllar alır.
Bak, iklim uzun sürede değişir. Yani
doğal şekilsel bölgelerin sınırlarının
değişmesi yavaş gerçekleşir. Ama mesela
siyasi bölgeler, şunun gibi, ülke
sınırlarını kapsayan, illerin
sınırlarını kapsayan bölgeleri değişmesi
kolaydır. Neden? Mesela İngiltere Avrupa
Birliği'nin bir üyesiydi. İngiltere
Avrupa Birliği'nden çıktı. Tak, hemen
çıkınca bak, sınır değişti, gördünüz mü?
İklimi böyle değiştirebilir misiniz?
Değiştiremezsiniz. Buradaki mantığı buna
göre kurgulayacaksın. Anlaştık mı? Bölge
sınırları da demek ki değişirmiş. Bölge
sınırlarının çakışması. Gençler, çakışma
derken şu. Mesela burası bitki bölgesi,
tamam mı? İşte ne diyelim?
Bozkır bitki bölgesi. Bozkır bitki
bölgesiyle toprak bozkır, kahverengi
bozkır toprak bölgesi çakışabilir
mesela. Aynı, aynı yerler hemen hemen
çünkü, değil mi? Ya da nüfusun seyrek
olduğu bölgeyle bu bozkır alanları
çakışabilir. Bozkır, yani bölgelerin
sınırlarının çakışmasından kastı da bu.
Evet, bölge konusu gençler çok basit bir
konudur. Çok kolay bir konudur. Mantığı
da size anlattığım şekilde böyledir.
Tamam mıyız burada? Çok kısa bir derstir
bu ama çok değerli bir derstir.
Özellikle şuradaki ayrımı yapabilmeniz
lazım. Bu ayrımı bir kere daha benimle
beraber şu boş çizelgede yapalım. Bölge
yazdım. Şöyle biraz kalınlaştırayım.
Bölgelere ayır dedi ve bunlara örnekler
ver dedi, tamam mı? Bölge yazdım.
Getirdim, ikiye ayıracağım. Hocam şekil
vardı. He, şekilsel bölge başına bir i
koyuyordum, iş oluyordu. Bir de ne
vardı? İşlevsel bölge vardı. İşlevsel
bölge. Sonra, şekilsel bölgeyi, hocam
şekilsel bölgeyi de ben ikiye
ayırıyordum. Doğal şekiller, beşeri
şekiller. Beşeri şekiller. Bu tarafta
işlevsel bölgeyi ona ayırmıyordum, o
tekti. Peki işlevsel bölgelere örnek
verecek olursak ne diyorduk? Kalkınma
işi vardı, değil mi? Kalkınma
bölgeleri. Başka, hizmet yapıyordu
devlet, Devlet Su İşleri gibi, hizmet
bölgeleri vardı. Başka, istatistik,
istatistik bölgeleri vardı. Başka,
kalkınma, hizmet, istatistik, ha bir de
yönetim vardı, değil mi? Yönetiyorduk.
Yönetim bölgeleri vardı. Merkezi
yönetim, yerel yönetim diye. Doğal
şekilsel bölgeleri nasıl yapıyorduk?
Hocam bunlara da işte bitki örtüsüne
göre bölgeler, toprağına göre bölgeler,
yer şekillerine göre bölgeler, değil mi?
İklimine göre, yani doğayla alakalı
olanları yazıyorduk. Beşeriye de
hammadde bölgesi mesela, hammadde
bölgesi, nüfus bölgesi, insanla alakalı
yerleşim bölgesi. Bu şekilde
yerleştirirseniz sorun yaşamazsınız,
işinizi görür. Evet, bölgeler konusunu
da bitirdik. Evet gençler, bölgeler
konusu çok kısa bir konudur. Önemli bir
konudur ama değerli bir konudur. Hızlı
bir şekilde bitirdik bu konuyu. O
tablolara bilmen üniversite sınavında
çok işimize yarayacak diyoruz. O zaman
ne diyoruz? Yunus Hoca ile bir defa
öğren, bir daha asla unutma. Kömürden
elmasa dönüşebilmeniz dileğiyle.